Well,
welcome to your mom's house.
Yeah,
I wouldn't do,
I wouldn't do that guys podcasts either.
Just to be clear.
All right,
we're joined here.
I just wanna make sure I'm right thing right.
Is it tome
well?
Yes,
yes.
Tome Tommy.
Do you ever get a,
by the way I on the phone sometimes it's super frustrating when,
I mean I could,
I'll say this,
I could tell sometimes it's English as a second language person has,
they'll be like your name and autonomy.
Like I'm sorry,
I'm like Tom.
And they're like,
could you spell it?
And they were like,
Tom,
like right.
Have you had heard this one yet?
Is this a new one?
Because like it should have been one of the ones you've heard a lot so far.
I do feel like it's super short.
Like it would be like a two syllable name,
like you know at least.
Yeah,
right Christine now like people can like go with your time is like,
it's so flat,
but it is.
It is like,
and then you could hear people go,
John.
I'm like,
no,
no.
I understand that.
What's more alarming or the amount of people who are so lazy that they've known
us for a while and they'd be like,
how is Christine doing?
But I'm like,
I've known you for five years.
For five years.
You haven't gotten her name right.
Oh,
we have these good friends of ours.
We thought they were pretty good.
They're good friends,
but we haven't.
And so they're in their defense.
We haven't seen him in like a couple of years.
They've been,
everyone's been traveling and says,
but it's been rough.
But you know,
we were pretty hardcore vacations that the data together that's close.
And she said,
um,
so,
and what grade is your oldest in?
I was like,
Angie,
the oldest?
Yeah.
It was like,
Oh man,
I guess we were completely out out of your mind.
You don't think about us at all now we forgot.
I forgot.
We forgot your child's name.
We hung out with and give Christmas presents to sometimes too.
You know,
it's like,
I'm kind of like defending us because we go and we,
we meet more people than most people do,
right?
Yes.
And you know,
there's,
there are clubs that everybody that you love and you walk into,
right.
And you're like,
it's so good to be back.
And sometimes it'll be,
you know,
let's say six or seven people on that staff,
right.
And they all say something to you and then you're like,
what's up dude?
Everybody did.
Yeah,
it's James Bro.
And you're like,
no,
I know.
And they're like,
they'll catch you.
That's the worst I just did this weekend.
I'm such a shithead.
I was in Saint Louis tits and my feature act,
I go,
oh,
hi,
nice to meet you.
And,
and like the first night went by and by the second night he goes,
know we've worked together before.
How long ago,
Bro?
He was like three years ago.
I'm such an asshole.
Sorry.
Out of you get a pass though,
I think,
you know,
headline or you get a pass.
It's going around.
You're meeting so many people working with so many people.
So popular,
so popular.
Yeah,
it's come on my favorite sometimes people go after the show,
they go,
you remember me?
An audience person.
They're like,
it's fucking San Francisco.
A couple of years ago,
I was the guy that yelled out pastrami sandwich and they're like,
yes,
you,
you yelled that out.
A Pastrami Joan.
Like you're like,
and they're like,
and then you said the thing back and you're like,
I know.
I remember now I just,
I forgot for a second.
You just jostled it from my,
how about when you're,
when the same thing goes down.
Hey,
you remember me?
You were in San Francisco.
I remember me.
Yeah.
Hey,
yeah.
How's it going?
Good.
Pascack hills high school,
right?
You remember?
Oh right.
Like it's not even in that context of the club.
Right.
And it's something from your childhood or your cousin or something and they're
like,
oh,
I'm off all,
I guess I don't remember you at all.
Well,
they say that forgetting names is means that you think more about yourself than
other people.
So you know what's wrong with that?
What about faces?
I,
I tend to remember people's faces,
but not always the name.
That means I'm half observant.
Maybe care a little bit,
but not enough,
but not enough.
And the truth is you remember the names of everyone that you want to remember,
right?
I mean,
right.
Christine,
so unmemorable I must not be
floors.
I just got it today.
It was like,
I love your podcast Christine.
I'm like,
what?
How much you love it?
Not that much.
Yeah.
Yeah,
we get that too about it.
Like in the,
you know when you do like press radio,
I think it's like,
so it shows like a level of just,
it's again,
it's like laziness and just as zero regard when they go like,
and then we have you on the,
you know,
and so they have a computer and they're like,
you're here.
He's got a great podcast called the good go over to you see your mom.
I'm like,
you couldn't just like type that shit in and read it man.
Like Google my name.
And they're like,
what is it called again?
I'm like,
it's fucking,
you have a screen in front of you and you just don't care.
Yeah.
Screw you.
All right,
let's open the show.
Here we go.
Papa's here.
Let's have some fun.
Here we go.
What's up?
A couple of questions.
I'm sure all of you
people are dying to know.
How do you wipe your butt with those long nails
was Randy,
don't bring anyone in loving.
Well,
well we'll go to your mom's house.
We can tone.
So
Christina.
Okay.
You got to tell him you got it.
Got It.
Good Times,
right?
Tom's good.
Okay.
Tom?
Skin tone.
Who's here?
How much did you hear that growing up?
Yeah.
Was like a real,
yeah,
you're like,
but then I owned it and I,
I took,
I got a better joke with my name.
You did?
Yeah.
It was a,
cause there was like a lot of Mama,
Papa,
a lot of Poopa,
a lot of that.
And then I came up with Papa boner.
Oh yeah,
it was,
it was the mic drop in third grade.
Sure.
Awesome.
Though.
That's the best thing about it.
Figure out a way to own the reverse.
The bullying.
They're like,
now you fucking love me.
If he could do that to his own name,
what could he do to mind?
Oh man,
that's so great.
Yeah.
Where did you grow up again?
New Jersey,
North Jersey,
North Jersey.
Is that like close to Philly?
No,
that's South Jersey.
North Jersey is like 30 minutes outside of New York.
Oh,
okay.
And um,
yeah,
like a right on the border of like New York state.
Yeah,
it was a,
it was a cool spot to grow up.
Yeah.
Giants Stadium More Than Eagle Stadium.
A Meadowlands is that,
yes.
Okay.
Yes.
Are you still a big giants fan?
I am.
It's cool to have that.
Like that's the thing about sports that like,
you know,
I think is great.
The longer you know you're around is like having a little piece of home and
having some emotional attachment to it.
Yeah,
that's what,
that's the fun part of sports.
Like I never get when someone's like,
yeah,
I love sports.
I don't really care who when I'm like then you're not getting the thrill of it.
Thrill is that you're either really excited or super bummed out and angry.
Yeah.
That's the fun part.
So you're having like a pretty good time I guess right now.
I mean it's up and down all the time,
but like giants are fun team.
The follow.
They stink this year though,
there's a lot of chaos,
but I'm also a Yankee fan and they just got in the playoffs and I come.
My whole house is girls who,
and nobody cares.
So I just like walk around
the house.
Like y'all yesterday,
Yankees were in the playoffs,
let's hear it.
And they're just like,
ah,
we don't know what that means,
but we know we don't like it.
That's how I feel.
Yeah.
It was completely mad.
And I went through periods,
especially when I was first dating my wife,
where I was like,
yeah,
you know,
I'll watch a little baseball.
But I was never like a all in sports guy,
like all the time.
Yeah.
But then like once we had kids and moved along and stuff,
I started watching more sports because it was just a way to shut down it.
Just kind of tune them out.
Yeah.
Tune everything out.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's great.
It's actually great disconnecting from your life.
Yeah.
Wife,
did you say why?
Yeah.
White.
Wait,
wait,
I can't hear you.
Yeah,
yeah,
I hear you.
It's interesting because sport Tog is a shorthand for gentlemen.
Like if you'll notice every time we do have a guy guests,
which is mostly all our guests now,
it's like sports first.
Oh,
we get it out of the way.
And then you're like,
what's your team was doing all right.
Good.
And then you can go on.
It's everything else.
It's like your,
your butt's sniff.
Yes.
It really is.
Yeah.
It's strange.
And then when you meet someone who is not intuitive at all and uh,
it's the kind of unsettling in a way,
even if you're not really,
yeah.
Weird saying.
Yeah,
actually.
Yeah.
I don't expect,
I don't expect girls to,
like,
I don't follow baseball at all.
[inaudible] but sometimes I'll meet a guy and he'll be like,
whoa,
you know,
I don't like really I think about baseball and I'd be like,
yeah,
okay.
But I get that like you right.
You like one of the things,
right?
You like something with a ball.
Yeah.
We don't have to be really smart to enjoy.
Now I hit up calm before the show and he was like,
I have a huge long nail.
Fetish.
Do you have any
of that?
Right.
I love them.
Yeah.
I'm no longer the better.
This is an email from his fight guy.
Say One of my favorite files.
Crazy.
Um,
but anyways,
they asked this lady,
how should I actually would think that too,
right?
If you saw these crazy long nail,
how do you do any number of things?
But why?
How did she wipe her binder?
She pick her nose.
How does she wipe her butt?
How does she work?
Shoes.
Ah,
ah,
all of it.
Demonstration demonstration or are you going to take a shit?
Good.
Okay.
So we can finally put the
central roll of paper like this.
That's like you got it on a paper towel
and then I do like the,
I've got a smell
nasty.
Oh wait.
Does she,
did you see the clip in the beginning and I don't want to direct you,
but did you see when the glanced by her foot?
Yeah.
There's a lot too,
right?
Yeah.
Those are all two.
We're going to talk about that too.
I'm pretty sure this lady was on Tlc.
I think we shot,
we saw like a super produced segment on her.
Oh my God.
Wait,
but
cause she want,
but look how much he's got to use so much paper.
This one we need to be day.
Yes.
Right.
Okay.
And then I'll take it.
Oh
No,
this is just,
I'm on tender hooks right now.
There
is a bike where she should only be,
yeah,
I'll take it and make sure you get all of it all up and see.
Oh,
she doesn't get that Sunday.
What about which is a real sloppy one?
No,
you really
got a really wide,
no,
she needs a permanent but day the washlet.
Yeah,
she needs a hose.
Yeah.
In a yard.
And a ma'am,
praise it in there.
Right.
It's somewhere with dead deadly accuracy.
This is just just a hands up against the fence and it's time to blast and you
just like let her collected throughout the day and then it's six o'clock at
night.
That's when your hose her off.
What are you,
what are you doing with your life?
You're not,
we're,
but I'm saying like,
yeah,
why would you inconvenience yourself?
Just to be like,
I'm the super gross long nails person.
That's her identity.
It's her mark as it is.
Right?
It's like I'm the parrot guy on the exotic pet guy.
The Boa guy.
Yeah.
I'm the Albino Boa.
It's funny.
We watched the,
we watched the whole segment on this guy in Mexico with the world's biggest
penis and it turns out that,
uh,
and it was absolutely enormous.
We're talking like down to the ankle.
But what they discovered when they did these cat scans was that the penis
actually was under all this extra skin.
It was like,
ah,
so penis actually was let's say whatever,
seven inches.
And then he had overgrown skin texture,
trunk callus skin.
Yeah.
Like al Roker extra skin like that,
right.
That had grown and,
and,
and give and give and give would give you the illusion if you're acting like
that's all penis,
but it really is excess skin.
So then they go and it,
Emily,
this guy can't go,
he can't walk.
It just flops against his legs and it's like [inaudible].
It's like an elephant trunk.
Right.
So then they go,
there's these doctors were like,
you,
you know,
you can't even enjoy life with this.
They offered to do a surgery.
We were like,
well we'll remove all this excess skin.
Still leave you with your above average penis.
Right.
But let you kind of function instead of living this way.
But which was like a horrible,
they showed like his quality of life and he was like,
Nah,
I like having this crazy huge penis and people being like,
Whoa,
like looking at me like the fuck is that thing.
Yeah.
Cause I'd rather have that right.
Then you get me back like a normal life.
So yeah,
he wants to be special.
They take that away from him.
He's got to come up.
He's got to develop a skill or a hobby or that's right.
He's got to sing.
He's got
to be something to be special.
That's true.
Now he's like,
here you go,
ladies,
rummage through this laundry basket and see if you can find it.
It's so bad.
And he's like,
it just drips all day.
So he's so complicated.
Yeah.
It's not even functional.
He can't have intercourse with people.
He can't.
No,
can't you just drape it over them like a,
like a parachute.
It's wrapped up in like a gauze
unusable.
It's weird.
It's kind of treats it like a,
it's like asking a Siamese twin if they want to split.
Yeah.
Oh,
here it is about your Siamese twin.
Can't talk.
Yeah,
so like here's how it hangs and there's just cloths like a horse and like
wrapped.
There's stuff wrapped on it.
Yeah.
It'll just chafe.
Oh that's not for decoration but may views and like a Mexican parade or
something.
That's opinion,
but see it's like a doorframe like okay,
this is from the lake,
that cat scan thing.
It's like penis is here in the middle and you're saying that this is penis.
This is like skin outside and they're like access.
Your penis actually ends way before all this excess growth.
I'm so confused and it looks like they skinned a horse.
I know this is just like a hi,
whatever tography scan.
But Tom,
you don't understand the medical.
Wow.
I'd say that is know.
What I like though is that whoever is searching for the penis guy is also
interested in dinosaurs.
Here's Princess of Wales.
That's why he does it for that moment.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
So walk where people go.
That Bay just for those faces.
Those faces.
Yeah.
We want to look at his apartment.
What else does he got going on?
I know.
No,
this is it.
That's the truth is I look at the apart.
Yeah.
That's his whole life.
Hey ladies,
I can make that work.
So why couldn't he have sex with that?
It looks like he could.
Well I mean I think with a normal sized woman,
but because it's all,
it's all like hardened skin,
the last inches of it or it's just calloused skin.
It's not even a penis.
It's like overgrowth of us.
You can still give kisses if you want.
You want to do that.
You could hug.
Do you?
Could you hug it?
Yeah.
Cause you caught all in it.
Totally shot with it.
You can hide a little peanuts in the top of it and see if your dog or your
squirrel can find
a,
that is really creepy.
But she grew it like she's deliberate.
What's worse though?
Do you think?
The hands or the feet?
That's the real question.
I mean,
the feet,
the feet seemed like a much bigger inconvenience.
I mean like these are terrible.
Nothing the doors and handshakes,
but like those,
you can't put shoes on those Tutsis.
Ah,
I mean it's just,
if we could just remove it from the convenience for her.
How about how disgusted we are?
I say the feed,
I can't even,
I can't look at feet normally.
Now you got these big jabber claws coming off.
I um,
AH,
real upset as I think I found,
I think this is her on the TLC show.
God See,
ah,
God,
that's so much worse.
So much worse.
Toenails prevent her from getting exercise she needs,
he says,
I can't exercise
beats that big toe.
Way Worse,
way worser
and worser.
Only way to normalize this is she found the dude who's like,
man,
it's awesome.
I'd like,
you know,
like there's a guy who's like,
this is perfect.
It's the guy who was like,
I'll take care of you.
I'll drive you everywhere.
I'll put your sneakers on,
cut the toes off so that the nails can dangle.
I'll paint them.
I'll make sure I punched anyone that gets a two yard.
His identity.
What are you looking at?
Sorry.
She's just shopping.
Just like the rest of you.
What do you,
right?
He's that guy,
This job is to get offended at everyone else's normal reaction.
Right?
We never saw a foot before.
You never saw an elegant ladies foot.
Not
that big toe.
So much worse than everything else on her toenails.
Oh,
this is a dance class
and she's got the big scissor hands up around his back as the toes are coming in
for her.
She ain't telling him like get a little too close.
Like that's your life.
Your life is like,
watch out for these nails.
Don't touch my nails,
man.
She can't work.
How does she text?
That's the most important thing.
You're right.
Yeah.
How she swiping.
That is what's his,
what's his problem?
He needs the enabling identity.
Maybe his,
he feels special being next to someone that he's perceiving US special.
You know?
That's the thing.
It's like this person is special right here,
man.
They got crazy nails when they befriended me.
Like that isn't guardians to be,
but what if he met her and she was just Kinda like regular nails?
No,
they slowly started to grow.
Oh.
And then he's like,
so baby thinking you're thinking,
what are you thinking about to Roto spa this weekend?
I got you a gift certificate.
They'll do both top and bottom because I don't even worry about it.
You pick,
he met her after it was big
for a while.
The thing is if you've ever had long toenails,
you know,
you know when they're uncomfortable.
Like when you put on your sneakers and you're like,
Ooh,
this is time to cut that big towel.
I think it's time to go.
Yeah.
Could you imagine like going past that?
I can't stand it for like a day she can lay in bed with someone now.
Right?
I mean you mentioned like that cutting you,
you'd be like,
Nah,
fuck.
That would be like for real like a knife.
Like somebody kicking you in a knife.
It's nasty.
She is the worst
back with their duty.
Definitely doesn't get off her shit.
Garbage,
garbage.
Is this Mexico City?
No,
the baby wipes.
Everybody voted here
with a nasty,
nasty or not.
She gets it.
I like
baby wipe.
Kind of just takes away any kind of bad feeling.
Well,
we have a baby.
Yeah.
That was not just regular paper you think were nasty now,
but look,
I got to think of any boys
were nasty.
Do you think that like knock long nail crew like she's like,
people think that people like us with these nails,
a collective
schnitzel Hayes long nails too,
and that's what this is all about.
Yeah.
She's like,
move on.
This is disgusting.
Oh,
I have to tell you something that happened to me.
A TSA agent.
I was flying to Saint Louis this weekend.
Comedy works sweatshirt and it said,
you know comedy works Denver on the side and TSA agent looks at me and she goes,
yes it does.
Comedy does work.
It's a good one.
All you got to laugh.
That's great.
I never thought of those words that way.
I guess if you didn't know it was a comedy club,
you'd think that too.
Like,
oh,
what a positive lady that is wearing that sweatshirt.
You gotta tell the crew comedy.
He said that,
that's really comedy and prayer.
They both
two main things that get me through life and laughter and Guy Craze.
Comedy.
Jesus.
Yeah,
it's a good one.
Yeah.
She was sweet.
Speaking of blind people,
somebody that we got,
we got a lot of questions about the deaf and the blind right
before you jump into that,
just off of blind people.
It happened to me at a club this week.
A guy comes up with is blind
and he goes,
can we,
hey,
can we get a picture?
Dave's blind and he's got the stick and he,
you know,
it is clearly blind.
I say,
yeah,
sure.
Of course.
Come on over here,
you know,
and uh,
his,
so it's me,
the me,
the blind guys in the middle and his friends on the other side and his friend
has them turn the other way.
No.
So it's the back of his head.
And I'm like,
I said to the blind guy,
he's messing with you.
He was like,
he does this every time.
Just let it go.
I'm never going to see it.
That's great.
I love that.
Have a blind friend you just messed with.
Yeah.
I love that.
Um,
email says hello mommies.
I have a totally blind neighbor that walks his dog around the neighborhood every
day.
The other day coming home,
I see him picking up his small dogs poop.
How do blind people will know their dog is pooping?
Oh,
not just smelling something or taking a break.
How do they find it and pick it up?
Keep them high and tight.
Big Fan.
Michael.
See on the surface,
that seems like a stupid question,
but now that I think about it,
yeah.
How would would,
this goes back to degrees of blindness.
Awesome.
Because you know,
somebody can be legally blind or you know,
medically they're,
they're considered blind and disabled in that regard.
But they might be,
have,
you know,
just see the can't drive,
but they see shadows and shakes and then there's like black out total blindness.
I think this is probably his neighbor is probably somebody that has some visual
ability.
He's totally blind.
I think so,
yeah.
Just figuring it out.
Super Blind.
Really good.
Stick dog.
Yeah.
He's out there with them.
And then you just wait for all of the grunting to start.
Yeah.
I mean,
you guys don't have it cause your dog so small,
but give a big dog.
They,
it's like a man like,
oh yeah,
no.
Yeah.
Are you being serious?
Ah,
Ooh,
I was what doing to do that through my dog talks.
Uh,
now there's no grunting,
but you,
you know what it is the jingle Jangle of like they're walking,
walking,
right.
And then they do that circle.
Yeah.
When they're getting ready as teaching,
teaching,
teaching made me as a poop bell on him.
Finding the specific place to grab though is kind of dicey.
Right.
I mean,
even with perfect vision,
you're like,
oh,
you,
you're real careful.
Usually pick that up.
Yeah.
That's a good point.
Because I,
I don't see that great.
And um,
but I,
you know,
I can see,
and it's hard to find my dog's sometime.
Yeah.
Especially when she just goes out in the backyard.
Well,
maybe,
so we've been getting a lot of feedback.
Maybe some blind people can can maybe back.
Maybe this blind person faking it.
I've done that before too.
No,
I liked it.
Like the Stena thanks.
Uh Huh.
No baby by fake fake pickup.
Hey,
you ever fake fake
one of those people?
I tell them like,
I can't,
I don't have the time for this.
And I put 10,
like I'm picking it up.
I don't want just all,
it's terrible.
Terrible.
Yeah.
I feel bad when I walked the dog and then I'm like,
she goes or I forget a bag.
Yeah.
And that's always when they,
when she goes to the bathroom in front of the neighbors are coming out of their
door.
So maybe now I'll just,
as we meet weekly,
go up the street,
I'll just yell.
I'm blind.
Gimme a break.
I'm totally,
by the way,
I have done the,
uh,
the Walkworth fuck,
I forgot the bag and you know,
and I've done the like the fake fake,
fake,
fake
stuff stinks.
It's true.
Before I had a dog,
I would always say that dog people are the worst because they would always find
stuff like they never,
you know,
and then once you have a dog you realize they're not just,
they're not bad people.
They're just struggling.
There's some days you forget,
some days you forget,
some days it's just dark out and went up our street and that right.
We'd take a ride on a big big dog,
shit flattened.
So like some of the stuff on it.
And then the next day I went the same route and there was a new one next to it.
So like this dog is shitting on the sidewalk and the person walked.
It's like,
yeah,
that's where you should be shooting here.
It was a collection of these big dog shits.
They're
nasty.
Super Nasty are tiny.
Yeah.
They make like cat shits.
It's,
it's never like,
you know,
fucking cuts.
Yeah,
there was,
we had a small dog.
I wanted a small dog.
Well as your dad say to you,
what did you say?
The reason we had small dog,
he says,
because the big dog makes big shit.
Small dog mix.
Small Shit.
Always get small dog.
He's a poet.
He's right.
He's totally right and like know the jumping up on people.
They get excited and say hello.
It said your ankle is no big deal.
My talks like a horse,
a lab.
Black lines are so cute.
They are great dogs,
man.
I mean people come over,
she jumps up,
she's just like same height as them and she does.
I mean she,
she shits like a man.
It's no joke.
She shed in your backyard.
Yeah,
she's ruined the yard were literate.
Right.
My wife right now is with a guy trying to figure out how to fix the art.
We,
we uh,
we call dog shit just like fence off an area and you train them.
It's not there.
I'll show you how to do it at our old house.
I let them shit everywhere and then the whole line is ruined and it's like a
mine field.
But if you tell them like this is your one area,
you just train them.
Okay,
come on dog.
Shit Alley.
And then he only go there just
for paying also.
No Brown,
Brown and yellow,
but the thing is it's going to mess up the grass there but it's rather than one
area.
One spot.
Yeah.
It looks like a mom.
I mean it's just all burned out.
The whole thing we're thinking about paving it.
Ah.
I think it's about just putting like seriously like put making it into a
patio.
Then
give it a whirl this morning.
Hi Guys.
I'm new to the podcast.
I've been thinking about this for years and I think you might have some insight
to offer.
Do you retired people dream in retarded tennis,
terrible or do they dream just like you and I are all the dream.
Are All the people in their dreams retarded?
I really liked to know.
Thanks guys.
Daniel,
that is a very insensitive question,
but I have to say you have piqued my interest.
I also would like to know from somebody if,
no,
let me clarify the question.
The question is do they,
are the themes of the dreams retarded?
No,
no,
no.
What they're asking is they're not,
you're not retarded themes.
This is all right.
I am,
I am.
There's absolutely shameless.
They're saying is a retarded person because we've asked before,
like,
does a retarded person know they're retarded.
Right.
And we've had a lot of people weigh in and like the people that teach special
ed,
sorry,
so an appropriate approach.
But this question is about dreams and whether or not the dreams are filled with
people that are,
oh,
also retard.
Oh,
just the,
uh,
just think that's not just what's going on.
Yeah,
I think so.
I think I would like to you,
they're not just really excited in the mall to see something.
It's not that kind of stuff.
It's like,
it's all chocolate.
I was,
did a show this weekend and there were,
um,
where were you people?
I was at a comics and Mohegan Sun.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
And uh,
they said that,
um,
there were two special ed teachers are,
there was a lot of special ed teachers.
Actually,
it was like two in one show and it was like a theme.
And um,
when I was a kid,
we had special Ed.
It was just for the kids who smoked pot and give the teacher the finger.
Right,
right.
And they are like,
no,
these are like really special needs.
They're like,
you know,
they really,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's a little harder.
Genres evolved since we went to school is what you're saying?
Yeah.
We had to do volunteer work or senior year of high school,
so a friend of mine and I owe as seniors,
we went to this special needs school and we would volunteer during our lunch
hour there.
Right.
The one thing that blew
my mind was the range of kids there were.
Yeah.
There were kids that had attitude problems right next to a kids that could not
speak like chair and couldn't move limbs and,
and you know,
like basically had zero ability to really participate.
Right.
About the question again.
I was too,
cause I was thinking about that kid and I was like,
I wonder if he dreams if he's just like,
hello,
how are you?
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like,
Hey,
he's in this shell where he can't get out and he's,
you know,
people think he's retarded.
But then in his dream is he like a recurring character of like a really good
looking businessman.
You know what I mean?
That's actually really interesting though.
Is he like stacked as he like in the Holt is the worst thing would be waking up,
man.
You'd like how you'd have these awesome dreams be like,
ah,
you wake up and be like,
Huh,
what a farmer.
Well I'd have to imagine to answer the question.
I'm thinking about it.
I mean I can dream about retarded people even though I'm not retarded.
So maybe the converse is true.
Have you ever drive different?
Not that I'm aware of.
I mean not yet.
Maybe tonight.
Cause we're talking about it.
You have very vivid dreams.
You remember your dreams alive.
I dreamed about pre judo this morning.
Close your eyes.
Ooh,
go ahead.
Retarded.
Retired,
retired.
Just look at that picture up there
of that guy.
Christina is more of a psycho high.
Hitler's thanks.
I just listened to your most recent episode,
had to ride in Christina's argument that she is less psycho and has a little
thing called empathy is false.
Okay.
Here is why we're Tom laughs at the pain of others.
The pain is generally brought on through their own actions.
Christina,
however laughs at mental illness all the time,
which in many cases the person can't help.
Clearly she is the main Hitler that's been culture.
Yeah,
that's really good point.
Good point.
Do you want to defend it?
Painful.
You know,
experiences of others.
Like I feel like it's a defense.
Can you please show just do we have the video?
They can pull it up.
Look,
I'm going to show you a video.
We're going to take a video and you just react to it.
However,
I'm not going to set him up too much.
Just okay.
When I tell you what,
how I naturally will know.
This is interesting that I,
I'm laughing at stuff that's involuntary.
Let's say mental illnesses involuntary.
Whereas this person is saying that those who harm themselves,
it's a voluntary.
Oh,
right.
Uh,
interesting.
So I understand.
Let's see the video.
All right.
I mean,
it's just like,
first of all,
okay.
I don't know.
Everybody has a different reaction,
but I,
I've found that it's,
let Tom Watch it please.
Okay.
Yep.
And his tone,
by the way.
[inaudible]
it's pretty funny.
I don't know his level of interest.
That's the driver like,
well,
how'd that happen?
Why are you so loud?
No drivers like you wrecked my car,
messed up the bumper,
walks away to us and even as he obviously doesn't like him,
doesn't give a fuck about that shit.
I don't know if it's funny they got hit or he's funny.
The reaction is funny.
There we go.
The reaction like the white,
whatever the common word he uses for Holy Shit.
Yeah,
he's pretty funny.
And then Ben is,
look,
yeah,
you don't think this is funny.
I,
because I,
I sense that he's in a lot of pain.
I feel badly for him.
I don't really,
I don't like the fact that no one's helping him and stuff,
but that's just me.
But if he,
if he reacted the way that you expect people in paint react like,
oh my God,
help me if I'd have the idea of empathy for him,
but that he's just making this crazy face and screaming these funny duck noises.
It's pretty much explanation overrides.
So this is the,
this is the whole thing.
The reaction of Tom is talking about that.
It's a reaction.
It's how he's reacting versus that.
Right.
[inaudible]
part of
it is if it were at all in English it would be different.
Yes.
You fucking kill my shins.
My niece is here.
Sounds like it's funny.
Oh my wife
Mofo guy.
Real areas.
Wow.
Christina loses that.
Another one.
That's a really interesting analysis though that,
that really,
now I understand
now I don't want to assume your,
you have children,
their pronouns.
Are you open to sharing them or no,
they day.
Okay.
They,
the end,
they use ams,
dams and those kids to those through them kids.
That's how they identify as them.
Do they do they what they identify as them.
They identify as those as those.
Okay.
And were they born with,
did you project your own Pronoun on them when they were born?
What?
Did you label them as?
Um,
hermaphrodites you did?
Yes.
Wow.
And they um,
disagreed and went to the,
to them those I believe he said,
and then we decided that they should be girls.
Whoa.
Wow.
Bolt.
Now My,
uh,
my wife is in school now.
She is going for her degree.
Really?
Yeah.
And she is in a gender class.
Oh really?
A whole semester of they in those and them's
fascinating.
It's endless.
And your wife and as a woman,
my wife is a woman and we have two girls.
And the thing for my wife as a mother,
when she was in,
in the class that you can't say that,
uh,
there was one guy there said she,
she said he was obviously trying to get laid.
Like he looked cool.
Yeah.
He was like talking about these guys,
all the light skin,
black guy with the cool hair and the cool jewelry and just listen to the
discussion and then raised his hand.
He's like,
I don't know.
I'm just feeling really,
I'm just feeling really sad for those babies.
Those babies are split up into boys and girls and I don't know,
it's hard not to cry when I think about those babies at my wife as a mother,
you know,
in their forties in the end,
the back of the room like oh Jesus.
Yeah,
because every dude off topic,
but every dude picks a to get laid,
right?
You guys are more overt with their choice and I play sports.
I'm good at it.
Well fuck,
like that's their thing.
And some guys are like,
I'm going to,
I'm going to show my emotions all the time,
right.
I'm going to be real deliberate,
but I'll hide it and make it seem like,
yeah,
I care.
It's all calculated.
My shoulder rubs and class
shoulder rubs the right after a heated discussion.
Do you want to,
you want to get coffee and talk about this?
I believe you said that.
That's the,
you look tense guy,
guy and that guy.
So,
you know,
now I have a kid to uh,
you,
you know,
even if I were to label Elyssa girl,
I believe to Europe,
she,
it doesn't matter.
I feel like that gender shit happens on its own.
You know what I'm saying?
Like my boy likes dirt trucks and I've done nothing to really to influence that.
Like I don't hang around them.
You know what I mean?
That stuff just happens.
Yeah.
Kids like we didn't,
we didn't know kids who obviously we didn't know if they've identified as a
girl,
but you knew it was very feminine,
very feminine,
attracted till girl type things.
But this is what's funny about my wife's class.
If you just said that you're constantly on the lookout for how you're screwing
up.
Right.
Oh boy.
So I just said,
so in the very feminine doing girl things.
Well what do you mean the girl things?
Dollies babies.
Why is that?
It is
cause it is because my son doesn't give a shit for those things.
That's what the whole class and she says she sits in class and all the people
like within earshot around her are all like,
no,
there's girl things and there's boy thank right.
Right,
right.
Don't you tell the teacher no union,
no one.
Everyone feels it.
Everyone knows it,
but no one wants to say it out loud cause it would get in trouble.
Yeah.
It's hilarious.
Toddlers a class last week and they brought out baby dolls and all the girls got
excited.
Pull them out.
My son took one look.
It was like fuck that and ran across it doesn't even want,
he's not interested.
Yeah.
Then is it isn't the teacher being like he should play with this dog and the
teacher told me that we,
he should excuse me,
play with that.
He,
we should kind of force their shit on.
I go,
listen,
I'm not trying to raise him to be a macho man.
I teach them to be gentle with animals and with whatever,
but if he doesn't want to play with a doll,
he's not going to play with a doll today.
Sorry.
Yeah,
I'm going to force him to do,
he's going to,
I have my kids may take it up.
God Damn Bro.
Yeah,
don't worry about it.
I clean guns in front of them.
Yeah.
This is what you're going to do.
It's still snakes,
rats.
Whenever it gives you a private school,
you,
you know,
you punch him in the face,
right.
We teach him that stuff at home,
just like healthy male behavior.
So wait,
tell me more about the getting,
getting lay guy.
So it's the,
and how old is he?
Waits till the next class.
I wouldn't be like,
you know,
I got a shoulder up today.
You know,
I was,
I was glad it was.
It was really upsetting.
I brought up that thing about the babies and I got really mad.
But then,
uh,
Carlos took me over to the side.
We went for coffee.
He's a lot deeper than I thought.
It's not just the jewelry may save sea turtles.
And that's funny because a lot of girls seen and shared thousands of times on
social media.
Take it on a South Glens falls,
high school bus involving freshmen air.
And Sweeter and friend Leo Washington who say the driver told students that
girls and boys need to said a different sides of the bus.
Do the couples in the past behaving inappropriately,
the pair identify as Trans nonbinary meeting.
They don't see themselves as male or female,
but proceeded to sit on the boys.
Then they say the driver got angry.
I try to explain to him the situation,
like our gender identity in situation and he was saying that he didn't care.
This is his bus and he's not starting the bus until he gets what he wants.
He said that after I told him that I was comfortable and I'm going to sit where
I'm comfortable,
the pair were then kicked off and waited for another bus to bring them home.
Thursday morning sweetener says the school's principal and other faculty stood
behind the to just be like,
Hey,
hi.
How are you?
What's your name?
What's Your Pronoun?
So they got kicked off that bus drivers an idiot.
I'm an asshole.
But just for being like,
no,
we want to sit here.
And he was like,
you're a boy or girl,
come on.
I gotta get my taxes are due,
I got to get to the post office guy does not like philosophic
driving it to do can't guy.
Can you imagine?
That's like when we talk about like,
like when I told my,
when,
when non-binary came into the lexicon and he was in was I called my parents and
I recorded it and I was like,
do you know about non binaries?
And my mom was like,
you know,
people that are neither boy nor female and like you could hear literally wheels
in their heads
like breaking apart and they were like,
I,
my dad's like,
I don't
a good bus drivers.
Totally.
That guy.
When my mother yesterday she asked what my wife,
how's school going?
I told her about the gender class and uh,
she brought up the thing about the babies and my mother just blurts out no,
as a parent it's your job to tell them what they are.
That's it.
It's like what does teaching them not exactly what they're saying not to do.
Now you tell them you're a boy,
dude,
get over it.
You're a boy.
Like boy things,
Shit.
I mean,
you know,
our generation,
we're learning every day.
It's,
I mean,
I mean we weren't talking about this last year.
Like it's coming swiftly and you're trying to digest it and trying to do the
right thing and trying to that generation.
It's like,
I don't know why my blood pressure's so high.
Yeah,
I can't,
I,
I can't sleep without paying five times.
What's your a Trans Hooey?
Yeah.
I don't care.
I also think about this sometimes even though I don't hear it really discussed
is how this issue,
and I don't want to like,
you know,
diminish the people that are going through their identity crisis,
but it feels like it is a not an issue that would ever be covered in a place
where they're lacking for food.
You know,
or at war if you're in the Congo and they were like,
hold on a second though,
why you keep telling me the lineup with the dudes I know.
Like wait,
what?
Like I'm not buying it.
And they're like,
why are you bringing this up?
There's a lion right there.
It's like,
it's only where things are comfortable that things like this become,
cause everyone's at me.
Yeah.
We're not in survival mode.
We're in luxury mode.
Right.
Theoretically,
the ability to make art as if you could be there and be like,
I want to talk about my gender.
And they'd be like,
you're going through a drought.
If you don't mind holding it until the spring.
Maybe we could talk about it then.
Yeah.
And that's to get all political.
But it was like,
you know,
the California and New York are kind of going through this and kind of
intellectually getting their head around it.
And then they tell people in areas where none of the fathers have jobs and
they're all freaked out on opioids.
And then they're like,
you've got to change your bathrooms.
And they're like,
dude,
we're dealing with some other shit.
Yeah.
There's no jobs in this town.
We grew up in.
And we're like,
yeah,
but you know,
everybody's got a p word and the power not now.
Right now.
I think that was,
I think that's what their reaction was.
It was like,
you know what,
you're not in charge right now.
We have other stuff.
We got to take care of her.
Sure.
To understandable though,
when you know,
yeah.
Your priorities,
not that.
Oh,
of course.
Um,
sometimes,
you know,
I dunno.
Sometimes you just need to make a change.
And I think this is a really good example of a change as somebody who needs to
make,
you know,
now at this age,
Martina desperately wanted it to look like Pamela Anderson.
So after 10 years in several cosmetic surgeries,
Martina transformed her looks into this.
Wow.
Those are pretty subtle touch.
She got done,
but she wasn't done six months ago.
Martina Med room wide headlines where they're most shocking transformation yet
through chemical injections and body modification.
Martina now considers herself a black woman,
are just the car and all the black people.
That should be our new screensaver.
It's so great.
That is dumbfounded,
nauseous,
angry,
hilarious.
Oh my God.
That is no amazing about this is that Maury Povich has to treat this like it's a
real treat.
That's the real trick of it.
He does.
This is like the most baseline bullshit,
like unethical on dignified and he's basically like this is 60 minutes.
Yes.
Reese's pieces.
And that's why he gets away with it.
Cause they're like Morrie's respectable guy.
He's a fucking doing garbage to me.
I know I eat the amount of CCS hand sanitizer in his dressing room after he
talks to you.
He's not,
you know,
like some artists,
hate their audience or their fans.
Yeah.
Imagine the level of like that he hates everything.
Yes.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Oh my God.
Cause he's definitely,
I'm sure a bit of an elitist Garvey and like to,
he is what he,
I don't know,
I did a radio show once and he was on,
we were both on his guests and he was talking about it and like he wasn't really
shitting on it.
Like really?
Yeah.
He was like,
he isn't elitist.
Like he's got these beautiful glasses and he's dressed,
you know,
like expensive clothes.
But he,
he doesn't either he's keeping some of the game really well or he really just
believes like,
no,
this is just what I do.
It's just a crazy show.
He knows that he is blessed enough to find a lane like this.
This is,
this is his lane and he's locked it in and he's made a great living.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
You see a couple of those tribes probably like no more.
Definitely going to keep doing.
Yeah.
Who is your father?
No.
Who's your father and he has a house in the Hamptons.
Yes.
Yeah,
for sure.
Definitely.
I can look at stuff that's shot.
He's so great.
Is the best.
He's confused and angry and upset.
Yeah.
I want them to look like a Barbie.
I want to create and what beautiful body like a Bobby was long,
blonde hair and long necks.
Oh my God.
We got breasts.
Look at those dates.
I'm not,
I'm not black,
so the black part of her,
I couldn't if I wanted that part.
I understand it's a cultural identity and it's really fucked up to just be like,
I'm black now,
but the tickets are like,
that's good.
Yeah.
Like it's not even good.
It has to hurt.
No one can wait.
You're saying you're saying it's not good.
It was like fucking sweet from where I'm sitting.
I mean maybe it's a girl,
good girl guy thing,
but
it was,
it was a pretty good,
perfect.
Let me get those for your wife.
Stretchy.
Special butter.
Also,
I got a nose job and I also had the liposuction to get along.
Bobby
faces a completely different,
yeah,
she was Kinda cute here.
Yeah,
just her face.
This isn't,
see,
this isn't terrible.
I mean this is ridiculous,
but it is a terrible,
yeah,
it's okay.
I mean those girls in her lane.
Oh boy.
So change my skin color and now and the route,
awesome skin.
She has changed her race and now identifies as a black woman.
Interview is going to go.
Wow.
That's pretty great.
That is so she knows the struggle now.
Yeah,
of course.
I mean all you have to do is change your skin color.
Right.
I called Shirley and I are boy,
we run in the industry now,
but I also liked to do photos.
What on the photos?
I should see if you have to cuffs off Pamela Anderson.
Yeah.
Photos would be much more better.
Does she look at that picture of Pamela Anderson and think I did it
like I got her looking at her necklace.
It says Black Girls Rock,
black girls rock did Maury.
I,
it's something tells me more.
He's production team gave that to her jewelry.
Jewelry,
shit on you was going to look great on you.
Crazy.
You cannot say we gave it to you.
Keep it.
That was like,
oh,
okay.
I got this in one zap,
stretching and w where?
When did you get injections to look darker?
This January.
In middle of January I got three injections in the belly and it's after the
first week.
You can see going down Daca and Daca,
but today is a pod.
This is going to put tanning salons out of business.
Three shots in the tummy and you're good.
You're good man.
Yeah,
I,
I I,
it's true.
Why would you even burn your skin?
You're a black person.
Yup.
I know you have to learn a lot.
Yeah.
Oh,
well she's open iron man.
No,
I feel a lot of this stuff.
I can feel it
just because your skin is dark at
beginning.
I only wanted to have more 10 yeah.
When I got my this injections.
Yes.
And two for three months.
Yeah.
I like the contrast of lung.
Okay.
Now I,
yeah,
I call us also changing.
She's,
he's fully floating on a civilian and I know,
yeah,
yeah.
She's really,
she's this range.
This is like a bus stop conversation.
When are you going back to your planet?
So that's good.
That's good.
Good.
And You keep looking right at to see where are you going to make a move and they
attack you,
so.
Right.
And that's,
that's more his gift is he legitimize is absolute insanity.
Is this one.
Yeah,
because he's also a dancing,
he's dancing the line,
like of asking a sincere question one yet.
Then he's also got a play to the crowd.
Right.
Knows it's bull shit.
He's like rarely,
but not too much.
She feels like,
oh,
you're totally mocking me.
Right.
Yeah.
That is probably his 10th show he's done today.
The delicate dance he does.
He really,
there's no,
that's why it's called Mori.
Yeah,
it's good.
Yeah.
I broke chaos as changing the wheat crowing Hess as it's a changing as all
right.
I can see my withdrawing house.
So a fake sentence version.
Yes.
Your husband Michael is here,
isn't it?
Michael?
Nice to see you.
Oh Man,
I might as well ask you,
do you feel black?
I am Indian.
I have got a doc,
Liam.
I'm a media guy.
He talks to dead people.
You also said I am black.
That is my race.
I can't wait to go to Africa because I hear the food is,
it's not,
it's not.
That's what I heard you saying it tonight.
Yeah.
You think anyone who is so good,
naturally black.
No.
I know some,
uh,
tech,
but,
and it's not to my attention to somebody and it's not a test.
It's not a media attention stuff.
Right.
I feel like homeless have mental illness and talk to people who want to talk
with me about it.
You know what I'm saying?
So
he just like walks like he's this like you won't be on TV.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There was a guy who was going to Penn station the other day and he was a white
guy,
like probably 28,
maybe no shirt on,
just like sneakers and like a baggy shirt,
baggy,
like running pants as an eating a sandwich and he's rolling on the ground.
He's getting up like aggressive,
like he's in a mosh pit by himself.
Like a ha ha ha.
You want to come down and talk about this?
Would you like to be on TV?
Yeah.
I love TV.
So we have,
um,
you know,
a lot of times we,
we feature dad boners on our show and a dad,
Boehner is somebody is a,
it's a dad,
somebody in our age range who gets very excited.
Um,
and we've,
we've had to then break it down into two lanes.
There's the UN,
like,
the real thrill is when somebody gets super excited about something they
shouldn't get excited about.
Like for instance,
um,
this guy excited about,
uh,
the,
the highway in Canada.
It's like,
why are you,
why are you this excited about a highway,
you know?
Oh.
Oh,
okay.
Oh
Wow.
The Trans Canada highway,
baby.
Beautiful Sunday burdens,
Columbia.
It's pretty great.
Oh,
I'm winded
story that this road towels,
he basically almost comes
one more time down there.
Middle.
Oh,
oh,
this is a downhill sucks fortunately.
Whoa.
That's like
really like peaked,
add boner.
Right.
Um,
then there's other ones where we feel like it's actually justify because it's
something truly awesome.
Okay.
In other words,
somebody will get excited about and it clips,
right?
But then you're like,
well that's actually something to get excited about.
But you guess,
right?
Yeah.
So somebody here's a dad moment this week,
but we feel like as a justified one.
Oh,
you can see why he showing.
Yeah.
It's always,
these guys are on a boat.
Jina Taylor,
give me the file log.
Oh wait.
Oh,
that one's over.
Losing their mind.
Oh,
y'all.
Yeah.
Get it.
I get that.
I mean how boring is fishing nor mine.
No sharks in the water.
I mean,
you've got more bay.
I am.
Okay.
I loved it.
It's great.
I mean that's why they're so stoked because it's been a born fucking bunch of
bullshit.
That's like the one thing that happened.
Yeah.
You want another beer?
We,
you always should we try over there by that rock?
Maybe we caught a fish or were there ones?
Yeah,
I know.
Oh my gosh.
So crazy.
It's so crazy.
Yeah.
Usually you're just like,
it's hot.
Still hot out.
Sun's burning me.
Hey,
how's work?
How's work going?
Sounds good.
Yeah,
she's still,
uh,
you still an hour commute both ways.
That's not so bad.
Not so bad.
Yeah.
You know,
you listen to podcasts and stuff.
It's really good.
It's good.
But to kill the time.
Yeah.
It is a books on tape.
How's Christine?
Great.
Don't even correct.
Correct.
Would be great.
She's great.
Um,
somebody sent in this boring in the same words.
I worked on this a show one time for comedy central about this called,
what's it called?
Like 30 minutes over Washington or something.
It was basically where we were mocking,
uh,
politicians ad campaigns.
And the way that there is one,
this is in Virginia where they tried to,
I guess use top gun,
but like this dude put out this
ad,
this is a real ad
for a congress man,
that guy is running for.
So like,
I'm like top gun,
it's got my vote.
No congresswoman Comstock.
And that's the,
isn't that top swimming Comstock back there at the bar?
Sure.
Is that you can't get her to hold a town hall.
You know,
it's funny,
he has a little Tom Cruise to his face.
Yeah.
It's got a little bit like someone in high school said he looked like Tom
Cruise.
Yeah.
And this is the moment where he puts it all to it at all.
I mean,
I know that his,
like his,
his campaign manager was like,
you're a vet,
you're going to wear a shirt that says a vet in these ad.
Right.
And he's like,
are you sure?
And he was like,
oh,
100% like you're going to O'hare veteran so that when people are voting,
they remember that part too.
Besides your awesome Tom Cruise commercial.
Can't get a town hall.
Do you one better than that?
We've lost that loving feeling.
No,
Dan.
Yeah.
Oh,
you ready?
Cringe or no,
it's so embarrassing.
Oh wait.
Can I put something over my head?
Do you have something like a news my face with
that extra his penis skin?
No.
Got her a whole town halls more with cans to chew.
Oh boy.
You're trying hard not to show.
The only mistake he's made is that he picked the wrong Tom cruise movie.
Yeah,
this is out of the straight out of cocktail.
All right.
This is a cocktail.
This cocktail.
What he's looking at the bottles and stuff and the whole bar stops and listens
to this is in top gun.
Well he's combining elements of top gun with this.
Oh,
you think that right?
No,
I think he's all top guns,
but he's made a mistake.
He should know.
He should have done,
I see interest a little Kokomo.
Yeah,
he should have been flipping bottles.
The craziest thing about cocktail is it like the whole bar stops and like write
w like hundreds of people to stop and like turn as Tom Cruise said something
about Tequila.
What's his,
his ad could have been like our district going to shit is boring around here.
Just like four drinks and be like,
let's have some fucking fun again.
But I I think,
oh boy,
boy,
oh I bought this works for him now you think so there was a lot of dopes out
there that are like this is great
fun.
Then the opposition walks out like she leaves.
Right.
Nice Work Dan.
Nice work.
Thanks Maverick.
Um,
damn.
Thanks Maverick.
Dushawn Dan,
however I approve of town halls,
bad singing and this message,
he's funny.
Good closing line.
Is Self aware?
I mean at the end he's aware that it's kind of Corny but a veteran teacher with
the army
case.
You're wondering what branch
he's running for.
He is a Democrat running for 10th district in Virginia.
Dan Hilmar wish you the best.
Dan.
I please keep making these really good.
Ooh,
that's so uncomfortable,
isn't it?
Like I'm sweating more uncomfortable than the nail lady.
The nail lady is like,
Whoa,
this is like the seat.
Like what just made you sad?
It's like,
it's like if someone tries to sing on those shows,
like on those audition shows where you're like,
damn it,
stop singing.
Like you can't do it.
No one told you I do.
We feel like,
why did it make us sad?
Because I think you can register,
especially if you're a performer when you're like,
this bad is,
this is a bad show you're doing.
You're not doing well right now.
Right.
Makes you uncomfortable to see somebody like,
or even worse.
It's when you're watching that person and they're killing.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
And you know it's bad and other people are approving of it.
They have.
Yeah,
that's true.
You're just like,
oh,
what do I,
am I that far from what that is?
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
That like,
oh,
maybe we're all just hacky.
Yeah,
it's true.
There's something that registers differently.
I think if you perform when you watch a performance,
yeah.
You read,
you read it differently completely.
Maybe that's what it is.
I'm going to go now.
Are you depressed?
I started think it was so out of his comfort zone,
like it was painful to watch him.
That's a good point.
Thanks Maverick.
We did it.
And he's just staring at whoever he's talking to because he's terrified.
No,
it's cause you know it's bad,
right?
Like he's not comfortable cause he's really an experience and I feel nervous for
him.
So I was like,
I'm so uncomfortable.
I want to do an ad like this for your NEP.
She has a Netflix special coming out on the 10th so it's about to come out.
What if you did like a,
hey,
why don't you watch my Netflix special and we like parody.
Do you like something from legally blonde or something?
I love lol.
Yeah,
for sure.
There's some good lines in there.
I object.
She's great.
It's a great way.
If you want to do it,
I love to do that.
And you can turn the camera be like,
I'm Christina P I approve of this message.
I like.
Totally.
And then,
yeah,
right.
Is there a better one?
Probably.
Is there a better worst idea that you have for this?
Tom
knows they're better movies with them legally blind like you would like to do.
Like is there another favorite Rocco,
that new documentary.
Have you watched rockers?
It's on Netflix.
If you went to the original rocky.
No,
no,
the Italian porn star Rocco.
He does.
We're about to wrap up.
Oh,
speaking of being bombed.
Yeah,
you'll,
you'll feel sad and stairs.
A lot of sadness.
But it's uh,
it's pretty good.
Right?
Amazing Donkey.
It's not one to watch when the girls are around.
There's nothing to watch from the girls room.
Literally nothing to watch.
But I just finished season three and narcos thing.
Big thumbs up to that,
finish that.
Excellent.
We started Ozark.
Yeah,
I did two really good.
Deep into that.
It is good.
But that documentary,
it's,
it's a wide range of them and this is a guy who's done really hardcore,
crazy porn for 30 years.
That's the part that I think the most that we stood like that stood out was
like,
you know,
if the guy was like 24,
you'd be like,
yeah,
I mean some people are going to go that way.
Right.
But like the fact that he's 50 something and he's like,
why if I have a couple of kids and then he's just like stepping on next and like
just hang and jasper hours,
you're like,
oh my God,
girls fast.
He's very revealing in it.
Like he can a deep dark thoughts.
Really interesting.
All right.
Yeah.
Maybe I'll watch it with the kids.
Uh,
Tom Papa,
where can people see you?
Um,
my podcast is called come to papa and um,
we've been doing a lot of live shows with it.
It's adorable.
Um,
just go to the Tom papa.com you can find and there's hot cast,
my tour dates,
all that stuff.
I'm going to Eugene,
Oregon next week.
Awesome.
Portland.
I did both this year.
Oh yeah.
Where are you doing Eugene?
Our Ri Alto and no,
no,
that's,
that's Denver or Loveland,
Colorado.
I don't know where I am together.
Eugene.
Some theater in Eugene,
the halts or the Holt's.
Okay.
And then one in Portland.
Two great towns or love going up there.
And Tom Papa was an amazing comedian.
If you've never seen him go see him live,
he's really one of the best.
It's really true.
It's true.
He's really good.
As a great to um,
normal person.
Christina P has a noose,
a special mother and warrior at premiering October 10th on Netflix.
You can cue it up wheat right next to your Rocco documentary,
watch them back to back.
And then I think I saw legally blonde parody about that special.
Yeah,
it's pretty good.
It's pretty good.
Um,
I have,
oh,
I put the,
uh,
the sign vinyls of completely normal or in the store if you wanted those.
And I also,
um,
the leftover posters from the Denver taping,
those are in the store as well.
Just did that right.
I did that last weekend.
I had it go.
It was awesome,
man.
Yeah,
it was a lot of fun.
Awesome.
Super Cool.
It's going to be a great special sidewall.
I'm excited for.
It never comes out as good as you think.
I know.
And it's never as bad as you think.
It's,
it's exactly that.
It's just somewhere in the middle.
Somewhere in the middle.
Yeah.
But always great for the fans.
Um,
but yeah.
Uh,
please go to [inaudible] dot com check out the,
uh,
the live dates.
I told you Toronto,
and uh,
we'll see you soon and the stories there as well.
Thank you,
Tom,
for coming today.
This is the best.
So good.
Love your podcast.
And I have a Bible that you invited me over.
So find the dogs.
This is a nice place.
If your time,
I'm sorry about the street.
I couldn't help.
Am I going to be able to go home?
No,
you have to stay here.
Oh,
how long?
How many days?
Just like six,
seven days.
Okay.
That'll be good.
We'll see you next week.
Thanks a lot.
Guys.
Smell
really,
really needs
me gay.
Oh.
Oh,
okay.
How often am I doing it?
You have to do everyday.
I do.
Dad.